peloton you know is the electric bike
company it got kind of popular during
during covid but it
i'd always heard it had these left wing
leanings
so i thought this is why i didn't get a
peloton i was thinking about getting a
peloton i thought i don't know i hear
it's fine or whatever but i said i heard
it's kind of lib i heard it's kind of
like a woke company
you know i hate to say i told you so i
was right
i was right so my producer
the
great ben davies texts me the other day
he says
michael i was using this exercise bike
this peloton
and
i typed in the hashtag let's go brandon
so all the people who were on the
hashtag let's go brandon could work out
together it was kind of funny we're
having a good time the next day i tried
to do it it was gone you couldn't you
couldn't log into it
peloton banned the hashtag
let's go brandon so i thought maybe it's
just your bike ben i don't know then we
start hearing it from other people then
people start sending the tip into the
daily wire
you can't do it and it seems like such a
minor thing but this is how the left
wins
all these little minor things
you suppress the let's go brandon
hashtag on the exercise bike
which is why by the way that's why i
would recommend checking out the echelon
exercise bike rather than the peloton
echelon a little more open okay a little
less
rigid and ideological and so i would you
know just these are just my preferences
okay but the peloton they say okay
let's go brain that's not gonna work or
facebook says no you can't post the
hunter biden laptop story or twitter
says no you can't post this thing that's
critical of say dr vauchy or the cdc and
oh it's just and you can't say this
thing in the classroom and oh this and
this and it's death by a thousand cuts
to say nothing of the huge laws and the
huge enforcement mechanisms at the
federal government even just at the
cultural level
all these little tiny things they all
come in together
to shape what we're allowed to say
the things we're allowed to advocate the
blm guy
you know blm that the terror wing of the
democrat party
blm comes out and says if you
push against the stuff that we want
we're gonna kill you that's what he's
saying we're gonna kill we're gonna burn
your place down we're gonna kill you
all these little things that shape
behavior
stop you
stop you from saying and doing what you
want living in the kind of society you
want ring it get that notification i
appreciate it sometimes you won't get
notifications even when you ring the
bell so head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe to
the michael noel show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you